On July 16th 1969, the nation watched...
Liftoff.
We have a liftoff.
...as US astronauts blasted off into space...
...on a mission to land on the surface of the moon.
Four days and a quarter of a million miles later, the nation's dream became reality.
The Eagle has landed.
Man made it to the moon.
The moment so surreal, veteran news anchors left without words.
Boy!
45 years later outside Space Center Houston,...
Yet today, I was speechless.
...Houstonians that witnessed the feat are still in awe.
I just remember being glued to the TV, to just being able to see the events unfold,...
...that it was larger than life.
To get from Earth to the moon, that's a huge thing...
...and so you just appreciate everybody who sacrificed to get us there.